how's it going brothers my name is
Pierre Dubois and welcome to a brand new
series called the art of fine art where
we're going to explore the many
different mediums of expressing fan art
fanfiction specifically in each episode
we're going to explore a different way
of expressing fan art fan fiction fan
art it could be anything from
sculpturing to finger painting to
macaronis anything and I want you bros
to join me on this
I would love to feature your fan art in
these type of videos too I think that
would be really cool no matter if it's
amazing or most likely like mine it will
suck ass I want to see it but for this
episode we're going to create fan
fiction fan art and probably the most
common way ever done you guessed it
Microsoft Paint let's begin
Oh Microsoft Paint it's been so long the
first suggestion Rose is Edgar and poets
panic what a great way to start you want
to select a nice pencil with this tool
voices spray I want the [ __ ] spray
the spray is like the [ __ ] there it is
that if you're real pro at paying do you
use the [ __ ] spray that Edgar or a
handicapped bunny no one will ever know
it looks like he's wearing high heels
let's go with that damn it yeah you can
look fabulous
let's give him those cross-eyed I study
heads so sexy there's me bro fisting of
course I want to be I want to be as
realistic as possible so let's go for
realism that's what I would describe my
art stylized realisable those yes those
are my men titties that's my six-pack
which are actually just rocks taped to
my chest and it looks like I forgot like
day oh did I just draw my my bulk hey
it's art you can't criticize it that's
the great part about this series I'm
really really starting to regret this
that's my my my left arm is a little
smaller I just realized I drew a picture
of me fisting my dog this is the bottom
after all these years we finally hit
rock bottom it doesn't even look like me
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] I mean the
muscles are real are the headphones of
course that's why you don't see it's me
I have a great ass also I forgot to show
that
my ass also rocks taped to my butt Edgar
of course is a he's blushing let's add
those kawaii cheeks being fisted is
[ __ ] [ __ ] up now what's great about
Microsoft Paint is the fill tool which
all get every time at least the leg
worked how about that damn I forgot to
draw his nips there they are and his
balls oh wait he doesn't have any oh he
needs a name hashtag fed girl the [ __ ]
in this shape my nipples are not that
big
grave digger Glenn says Frankenstein's
monster with short arms fighting a robot
we changed so arms and rocket launcher
nipples anything with rocket larger
nipples I will draw ok Frankenstein's
monster
he has very perky lips and I eyeliner is
on point you should call it
Frankenstein's hot date am i right
alright I'm really quite the shark
artist I'm actually trying on this one
it's kind of sad that left shark that
has to be left shark you ok there right
shark you don't look too good
let's never forget the blushy cheeks the
blushy Kawai cheeks what left shark is
splashing to could there be hidden
romance
okay so here's the robot he has chainsaw
arms god damn this is such complicated
what the [ __ ] am i doing what happened I
thought I was good at this there's one
[ __ ] big [ __ ] fish going on in this
picture I don't even I can't even there
it is
now it's disgusting Frank robot nips
beautiful fan fiction fan art I'd rock
at those nips if you know what I mean
so so so so many of you bros are
tweeting to me starik now i don't know
what the [ __ ] tarik is i google it
still don't know what the [ __ ] it it's
plates from Teen Wolf teen [ __ ] world
fun alright we had this guy and that guy
and oh my god [ __ ] kind of show his Teen
Wolf let's be honest here you just want
to see them [ __ ] so let's just let's
just do it and have it done alright now
this is art this is [ __ ] art yes oh
I'm doing it oh it's oh this is
happening
he has feet as legs because because his
nips will actually hold him up he
doesn't he doesn't need them he's
waiting for that insertion but instead
he gets
get something else surprise so this guy
is beardy see that guy is beardy which
makes for a perfect to use of this brave
get a good grip on that ass
and shiny sweet ass
he's also crying by the way I don't know
why is he happy if she's sad we don't
know it's art it's not supposed to tell
you all the details but what is this oh
no oh oh that oh it's out it's there
this really speaks to me I gotta say
this is getting too weird I'm gonna opt
out I'm not even gonna name it I'm sorry
I'm sorry Teen Wolf fans Juliana Dempsey
George Bush and an actual Bush Juliana I
like your thinking it's been after work
Josh bish is tired from a long day of
being the president
except he's not depressed anymore and he
can't really get off the way he used to
take a seat on the couch
and just spread his legs
hashtag manspreading and why did I draw
that that just happened I'm sorry
and he's also crying and I don't I don't
know why and then we have yes we can use
our amazing spray to will hear again the
bush the actual push it's a large juicy
wonderful push persists oh it's also
blushing brush don't be shy Bush which
Bush am I talking to here the [ __ ]
mild life anymore George Bush penis has
a smiley face on it and they're just
brofist ting the question and Bush
they're just they're just chillin
this is great a ship sailed what was I
doing again
all right press this has been amazing so
far but we have time for one more
Gannon fast suggests make me a unicorn
shake Daleks yes yes what was that what
was the point
oh yeah the unicorn listen is a normal I
[ __ ] it as a unicorn it's not a unicorn
horn properly without a butt
all right friends amazing to create a
fan fiction fan art with yesterday leave
me suggestions on what you bros want me
to paint in the next episode next one
we're gonna do finger painting now I
want you brothers to submit your finger
painting of your left finger and right
finger having having you know I want to
say anything else
that's what I want to see in the next
episode you have one week bros leave
life enjoy watching Bruce and I will see
you Bruce a lot of bros do - bro bro I
will
what Jesus what's that